I can't get enough of
French that they speak
the reason they speak French here is
actually because France had a colony up
here in current Day Canada but the
British were fighting the French and
they took over this land and they kicked
out all of the French people some of
them went back to France into other
colonies but then the Spanish who
controlled New Orleans decided they
needed people to like settle here and so
they're like let's take those French
Exiles and recruit them to come settle
these swampy areas and that's exactly
what happened so a bunch of French like
Exiles came here settled and they kind
of isolated themselves in the swampy
space and developed their own language
and their own Fusion culture that we
know today as Cajun language and culture